اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره مرحبا بكم اصابه مراسل الجزيره
وائل الدحدوح والزميل سامر ابو دقه في قصف
على مدرسه في خان يونس وذلك بالتزامن مع
سقوط عشرات الشهداء والمصابين في الغارات
والقصف الاسرائيلي العنيف والمستمر على
قطاع غزه وتجدون المزيد من اخبار حرب غزه
في رابط التعليق
الاول الاتحاد الاوروبي يقرر فتح مفاوضات
انضمام اوكرانيا الى الاتحاد في وقت لم
يعد الدعم العسكري الاوروبي بالوتير ذاتها
التي كان عليها منذ بدء الحرب من جهته رحب
الرئيس الاوكراني بالخطوه وعدها انتصارا
لاوكرانيا ولا اوروبا
برمتها محافظه سيستان وبلوشستان الايرانيه
تعلن مقتل 11د ع شرطيا واصابه اخرين بجروح
جراء هجوم مسلح على مقر شرطه في مدينه
راسك جنوب شرقي البلاد المحافظه قالت ان
عناصر الشرطه دافعوا عن مقر الشرطه وكبد
المهاجمين قتلى
وجرحى بلومبيرج تقول ان افقر دول العالم
تواجه ازمه ديون كبيره حيث تدين هذه الدول
بمبالغ تريليوني بفعل اسعار فائده مرتفعه
واعاده هيكله غير عادله في وقت بات فيه من
الصعب عليها ان تواجه تحدياتها الاقتصاديه
والاجتماعيه الىى
اللقاء